today on our show Wonder Woman wages and
a watchman we do that's what we're going
to talk about today on fat man I'm
Batman
that men on Batman welcome The Fatman
Batman I'm Kevin said Bernard a Wonder
Woman continues to dominate at the box
office how much has it made mark five
hundred and seventy eight million
dollars worldwide okay so it's done all
right it's you know nothing to sneeze at
good lord
well who everyone could have guessed
this yeah I mean a long time coming she
has never had her own movie and if you
make it aw damn movie for an audience
that is underserved they [ __ ] show up
in droves totally and the drop off week
after week has been record-setting
release small most comic movies fall
pretty hard secondly sheep maintain
sixty seventy percent
she held she Alex Felice arrived in
no-man's land she did the whole world
was in her head and then and then and
man and man and then and then and then I
am nomad I am died enough to mascara
sexy you know what she didn't get though
what hey all the money's all the money
story broke this week a specious story
at this yes backed by not entirely solid
numbers it's a true story but not you're
missing a lot of information the story
who publishes al dell.com
published a story that said that gal
gadot was paid $300,000 for Wonder Woman
and they said compare that to Henry
Cavill who was paid fourteen million to
be in Man of Steel I read that and I was
like I know that's not true
that can't be quite there's no way on
earth even get fourteen million for
[ __ ] Batman V Superman get for
[ __ ] man he might never get fourteen
million I'm glad he's not because it's
not good actors wonderful guy but like
they're not paying that money anymore
that's debt money that is Downey jr.
money you my kid won't he's [ __ ] more
things like forty mine yeah probably
yes hours before guy what like thirty to
show up for a half an hour and force
awakens and run from those around
monsters pretty much oh god damn it
Julie and get stabbed but to do from
guys I like what the good actor man I
never watch that guy said guy girl I'm
sorry the opposite I never watched that
show but he's [ __ ] to open that movie
he's great I saw him in something else
recently Isaac
like I was really good actor all right
so wait Wonder Woman
they said underpaid gal gadot three
hundred thousand Henry Cavill got 14
million what the [ __ ] as a clickbait
kind of thing yeah henry cavill ingot
fourteen million to be in the movie
henry cavill is paid what four hundred
thousand something like that so there's
a gender gap definitely pay gap of a
hundred thousand bucks between Wonder
Woman and Superman which is yeah if you
want that the story absolutely totally
but fourteen million that's what he got
all in back and with the bonuses and
[ __ ] once the movie went into high
profitability which means that gal gadot
unless she's got a crappy ordeal in him
probably has the same perks and bonuses
based on box office performance built in
her contract which very well means she
could [ __ ] and walk away with as much as
he did if not more I think this movie
might wind up doing better than Manistee
it is entirely possible and I think that
some of theirs also based on merchandise
sales and like rights facial rights
licensing but they will sell a [ __ ] ton
more one-woman toys and they did a
manage any idle mentally agree much
absolutely like she she will come out
quite alright for this and because this
doing as well as it's doing and showing
really no signs of falling off mmm she's
get to renegotiate a contract for one
woman to trust machine a mega three
hundred thousand bucks and no no and I
can also to put this into context stars
for superhero movies are often
especially for the first adding paid
very low Marvel was the king of like low
balling everybody Hemsworth in Thor
Emsworth and Thor gets one hundred fifty
thousand dollars oh my god you're
kidding yes under fifty thousand dollars
Adam driver got five hundred thousand
for Star Wars Force awakens cuz again
he's the villain you know he's he's a
super important part of it I don't know
what Daisy Ridley got but it probably
wasn't bad any but also he was on girls
she was on going yet like like rapid
even like he's been working Daisy Ridley
I'm sure did something but that was the
big that was the big movie for her you
know nobody's getting too big movie for
him to but he's been in movie play
yeah he's in Paterson I think last year
the denominator like he's done some work
he's in that scene of saying that this
is where I leave you
yeah and for the stores but regardless
right I can argue about his wages
everybody gets six figures when they
start these things either admit or Lowe
says you know why because the star of
these movies is the character that's
what Marvel says Marvel's like we love
Robert but the star of Iron Man is Iron
Man
yes except and this is the thing Robert
was a last one to get that kind of money
yeah could be like hey I'll be in your
Iron Man movie you've got to give me
like 5 million to be an Iron Man I want
it really badly and I'll pay for the
insurance out of my own pocket but I'm
still a movie starting out to get me his
money and when he signed for Iron Man 2
he got [ __ ] cake well it's close but
yes you're absolutely on the first movie
they fought his hiring tooth and then
they didn't pay him anything he worked
for I'm not gonna say scale but he I
don't think you got 5 million I think he
got something he got entry-level hundred
fifty or three hundred but it was not
huge not huge and then they only had him
for one picture yep and then the movie
took off and they went back you know for
two and then he was okay it exactly on
his money I think that was a movie got
2530 and then it just kept going
Avengers like you get him for Avengers
you're gonna pay him 50 million dollars
to show for event you put him in civil
war suddenly the Captain America sequel
is part you know [ __ ] Iron Man
suddenly the spider-man movies part
Ironman like he just keeps collecting
but again he it didn't start that way
like you know he was considered risky
and they didn't want to pay him and [ __ ]
like that and then when there were sweet
rewards he made sure he got some and
continues to [ __ ] it up and also from
what I understand made sure his fellow
actors got some of these all got some
bumps for Avengers because he helped to
read a guy okay come on if I'm gonna
show up and we can't do this without
everybody everybody's got to get a taste
he's a good guy but he's got a great
agent whoever the [ __ ] is his agent
deserves it but but Marvel their beak a
little post Downey absolutely clamp down
on what they're paying their stars
because they realize they're going to
have 30 of them in Avengers 3 that's why
they're all going to die an Avenger kids
so that they ought to pay their
exorbitant salaries anymore
introduce Kitty versions it reminds me a
bit of Brian cave ons why the last man
deal ago which was for vertigo the last
time they were given way rights because
he made so much [ __ ] money off of Y
the last man translated into a dozen
languages printed all over the world
like he bought houses off the Y the last
man money and vertigo said to themselves
you know what we have to stop doing
giving this [ __ ] away flexes crater on
digits creator-owned and you got to keep
it even vertigo stuff today is create a
participation right but you can't take
it out of the Warner Brothers you can't
do anything there first you got to go to
yeah you can't leave Everett they learn
that on read with Juan Ellis for a while
still I'm preaching to the yeah creature
is not at one of those I mean they get
some like vanity credit for vertigo but
it in vertigo jammy-jam innate a Warner
Brothers show and if it's not a vertigo
jammy-jam as we say in this business it
could go [ __ ] itself yes first I've
never heard that expression back to
Wonder Woman back to one room see yes
yes she was paid less than Superman yes
it's a crime but no it wasn't
13 million change yeah more than or less
than see it wasn't like a salary hate
crime it was just a no and I'd say I'd
look out no [ __ ] from [ __ ] but if her
deals anything like Henry gavels and
she's gonna clean up on the back end
just because I guarantee this movie is
going to surpass yeah Superman right now
it's like number two at the box office
and it's gonna be how much five five
seventy eight million worldwide and and
I'm to deal with like seven and change
been democratically I mean not for
nothing like don't jinx it there's a
chance to talk to Wonder Woman gets
close to Batman V Superman's grosses I
think it which was eight eight fifty
eight eighty yeah I think it definitely
beats Suicide Squad
but with that that went to seven fifty I
think and again I think it crests too
easy eight fifty before and they will
keep it in theaters for a good long
while you got every last bit of it
here's those think about that movie
you're doing a sequel the only person
coming back really gal yeah Steve maybe
comes back and some you know flashbacks
or [ __ ] a ghostly image of the
[ __ ] bore as the motion manner which
we pitch last that is that's right
please use that patty Jenkins can you
hear me patty can hear me but that is
good idea but you know technically the
only one they need back sir everyone
else's go ahead yeah more war one so
they died of what they died from World
War one they all got World War one gay
was allergic to bulletin so they it's
not an expensive sequel from from the
cast pointed you know like view bringing
back a very expensive cast and they all
lived [ __ ]
especially because movie did
unexpectedly well they knew as you do
weapons it don't better than anyone
expected so at least they don't have to
do that now I get Star Trek movie where
you got to bring the whole [ __ ]
bridge crew back that's true the burden
person they don't have the option on to
bring back so far is patty Jenkins hold
on to my spit take are you serious they
haven't locked that up yeah they have
not locked that up yet DC lock that [ __ ]
up
lock it down put a ring on it Oh monk ya
better put a ring on that's crazy yeah
that's honestly like I think she's
getting more press than gal gadot off of
this movie like every day open up Google
News there's a patty Jenkins on it yeah
so they should it's crazy
Babbitt's either you and it's gonna cost
them [ __ ] money because we think she
got paid first time.if gal got 300 she
can get more in gal no way they paid the
director more in the [ __ ] store the
movie yeah I mean I don't I don't know
how that works in that studio math how
many think ends and say let's say tops
tops she got what [ __ ] gal got 300k
yeah what does she get for a second one
I mean if I'm her for the second one of
these things and you don't pay her like
seven point five or ten million dollars
to show us I was gonna go five you want
to hire I mean did so much of the reason
why this movie works is because it's
because of her because of the things
that she fought for because the places
she dug in her heels and said no you
have to do a no man's land sequence this
movie lives and dies on whether this
works or not and here's what we know
and I don't think honestly if for
nothing else been a PR reason right
despite the veggies immensely talented
and she did a great job but if they
would place her and if they replace her
with a dude which there's no rumor of
that or anything but he's just
speculation I'm speculating especially
because Hollywood has been known to do
dumbass you make chef will give me
example uh you know who directed the
first Twilight movie a woman named
Catherine Hardwicke yeah you know and
it's a whole like why a thing it's about
this young lady fossil female lead Ella
it makes I don't know a lot of money
alien dollars it directs the second one
Chris Hardwick her brother The Nerdist
it's like David Slade I think of that
long ever it emerge it brought in a dude
and then all of them are made by the
rest are made by dudes and it's like
okay I guess we weren't paying that
close attention to that kind of gender
balance that won't happen again it can't
possibly happen here so Jake his name
probably go down cinema history because
looks like it's going to be a turning
point for female directors in the
previously big boys club of comic book
movie making yeah I mean and it's also
kind of never you can see it gonna be it
I remember seems now a bunch of girls
out there and women grown-ass [ __ ]
women or seeing patty Jenkins do what
she did now they're gonna go bit her
missing some picture of patty running
into Ava Duvernay
at some Academy Award function or
whatever and it's like oh yeah by the
way here's the highest grossing female
director of all time here's the first
black woman to be handed more than
hundred million dollars to make a movie
which will be a trickle and wrinkle time
you know and then there's Ava Duvernay
editing suite on the Disney lot is right
next to Ryan Coogler editing Sweden so
don't you lack that live into the
spotlight walking back and forth between
each other the chicken [ __ ] out like
it's what a different Hollywood we're in
right now absolutely like we live in
wonders times when this is the world
that we get and it's all delivering on a
way that surpasses expectations and it's
also like you know how about how about
this how about fresh take on something
you know you're not going to get that
out of the same person you go to over
and over
again and I'm not like [ __ ]
mansplaining this nor my [ __ ]
betraying my gender chip but like a lot
of dudes particularly a lot of white
dudes in some movie stores for years and
years and years and years so much so
that people will audiences can predict
the endings of these stories and stuff
like that not chalking it all up to men
but largely been in charge you get some
fresh voices in there ain't white it's
not a white dude like and I know I just
alienated a lot of right-wingers but
it's you gonna get a better [ __ ]
story on how to say it Mandic why
because it's a fresher take so
somebody's never done this story before
like he said man you put Jenkins on
Wonder Woman she fights for that [ __ ]
no man's land sequence they marketed the
whole movie on it it's the most
memorable sequence in the movie it's
right it's a bit in the trailer where
you're like holy [ __ ] we're onboard it'd
be good yeah this could work so more
power yes patty Jenkins and Ava Devore
nice Duvernay do Benes and the Ryan
Coogler zuv the world can we stop for a
second though to a side track or sidebar
sidebar wonderful I'm doing very well
yes
for some reason somebody dug up the Joss
Whedon script this weekend online on
Twitter is one of those things about
Twitter really like without fascinating
somebody I don't know the lady who dug
up the script for Joss Whedon's Wonder
Woman gave the read and started like
live tweeting the script yeah and
sections and mine which you wrote like
ten years ago I think yes
but to be fair he did write ten years
ago but he did write a post Buffy yes
and boy they just [ __ ] went after him
again so weird I don't know that guy he
seems like such a sweet guy
I remember remember after Avengers with
the Black Widow thing mm-hmm like
everyone he had to leave [ __ ] yeah
yeah glad we left the online world gives
he's like again take it and then just
for no reason like they pull out an old
script of his and they're like this
dude's a dick and here's why kick him in
the balls for 45 tweets I'm alone okay
yeah daddy was that that was like yeah I
mean like what was that this is now but
still he did write Buffy why you'd write
Buffy you wrote here
years and he had help and there were
other writers but it is his brainchild
and it is a female lead like long before
you know everyone's like is amazing that
they're doing Wonder Woman there's never
been a female lead before given many
female leads before but you know just
maybe not as high-profile as Wonder
Woman woman right in the name and stuff
but I just watched recently and I know
I'm gonna get crucified online for
saying this but [ __ ] them
I watched Charlie's Angels recently know
he's dangerous plays like a Marvel movie
go back and watch it is they they're
they're [ __ ] super heroines without
the map you even have secret identities
it's crazy I watched that flicker done
like wow this is totally [ __ ] works
you know Supergirl had a movie Electra
had a movie they'd our enemy Riku
Catwoman
but they did have a movie and stuff like
that but still that's not the point
point is you going after the guy that
like for a while he was the only person
who could give you something you know
that looked different like he wasn't at
least look look at me whenever I tell
story I'm like stew dudes and then I you
know whatever they're in space or God or
in front of a convenience store but at
least this dude was like oh the hero is
a girl who you know is the Slayer and
she's like I'm not even a weed an
apologist or anything but like I thought
that was unnecessarily yeah I get cruel
but just like why do you kick him in the
balls for you know [ __ ] let's all be
happy there's a great Wonder Woman movie
instead of [ __ ] on the guy who wrote
a movie that you didn't particularly
care for that never got made never got
made I mean I get the the tendency
towards looking at somebody who you've
seen as an ally and then realizing that
at some point in his past that there was
a mindset that he had that didn't fit
into what you thought an ally would
would produce yeah and like who the [ __ ]
knows what kind of studio notes you got
who knows what war mothers insisted that
he do on one oh man I'm not apologizing
from either all right that madam once
seemed like a nice guy
I loved Buffy I love fire you love stuff
I love all of that [ __ ] all I'm saying
is you have no idea the circumcised to
be high mad script and you always have
to allow for somebody to understand that
they did a shitty job and rectify that
and you want to be better at that thing
that you do
to be fair like when one a woman open
like he was one of the first people I
thought we like I saw it
Paddy's records yeah like he blew her up
and stuff so I know it was just a weird
kind of sidebar of like really like I
mean it's what made that maybe that's
the reason it did not commit yeah I mean
I remember like when I first heard that
he was writing one a woman with her go
[ __ ] yeah job and when were mad enough
loot and then I spoke to a couple people
who were on the inside he's a cat script
not so much yeah yeah and it's like okay
well clearly seen her Minds prevailed
and they decided not to make it and and
and also like he's good dude and he's
made great stuff but like look everyone
lips from time to time yeah especially
produced that much [ __ ] material
should take you from the king of whips I
know but you know maybe maybe it wasn't
up to [ __ ] snuff don't mean is that
Batgirl is going to be bad
no tell you what man he seems like a
self-correcting animal you know I
guarantee you and he seems very very
[ __ ] self aware and sensitive I
guarantee you if he sees that it's gonna
factor into his [ __ ] Batgirl script
like yeah and then and not for nothing
but there was very little to compare a
Wonder Woman script to ten years ago and
say [ __ ] point here's the bar that I
need to clear and in the world Post
Black Widow which whatever you think he
did with that character whether you like
her or not she's a major player in the
Marvel Universe Post Wonder Woman there
is no way you can't deal with Batgirl
and the femme part of the bad universe
with way more sense of responsibility
than you might have done previously is
there a world where they're like maybe
we get back a little woman or there like
that okay Joss Whedon they did Buffy
with crazy again come on get over
yourself or is there a world where
they're like hey you know like we gave
one a woman to a woman and survived
somehow worked out anything to like it
maybe we should give that girl to a girl
and see what happens
it's you know I'm not trying to take
anything away freedom is great but it's
like if I like maybe and maybe maybe
like you don't give a [ __ ] about that
online conversation I guarantee this I'm
the guy directing Batgirl and I read
that online Congress
about like did you ever read his Wonder
Woman well the first things goes to my
head is like I should not do that girl
and I'm an idiot I wonder if like
there's any part of him that's just like
yeah I you know there's there's a
version in which there's a multitude of
ways of biscuit dough there's the he's
just gonna [ __ ] do it because he
wants to do he's got a great take on
anything's just the right story and he's
gonna write and direct it there's a
version and again he made Buffy in which
his female made Buffy and he made the
Avengers and he knows what he's doing
there's also the version where it's like
you know what I'm going to direct it and
I will Co write it with a woman because
I want my perspective there's a version
which he just produces it and oversees
it like sort of Feige style like the
Lezak Snider we always hope that Zack
Snyder would be the actual like puppet
master who's orchestrating all this [ __ ]
and he's the Godfather above it any of
those things would be fine I think he's
got a sensitivity for this character and
for this world that is only a benefit
and not a hindrance I agree um alright
enough about that Nevada you guys not
part of the process [ __ ] speculating
on [ __ ] way above our pay grade let's
move on to another one of those a Wonder
Woman and Conan the Barbarian yeah it's
on that
yeah just comic book news that's [ __ ]
comic book with these DC and Dark Horse
are going to Co publish a six-issue
miniseries written by Gail Simone oh
well sweet Gail and art by Anne Lopresti
who did the Wonder Woman run from Jim
his name is Aaron Lopresti title yeah
yeah oh I'm not being this guy man what
a female writer well I think it's more
that they were on Gail's Wonder Woman
run together pear I believe it I'm not
good but it's it seems like you could
the way the world is going now people
are starting to wake up to go like maybe
we should turn those genders over to
those genders those races over to those
races you know no fan I'm not lobbying
for I'm just saying like in a world
where Gail Simmons writing it like you
could also get a female artist to draw
it and then you got you got something I
guess with that a lot of people excited
calm
is by and large a nostalgic medium not
that serious a boys club also is
somewhat backwards-facing medium in that
the here's the thing that worked at
people like let's just do it again right
which is hey remember everybody loved
Watchmen before Watchmen hey number one
everybody loved that thing let's just do
that again okay remember we reboot an
entire universe let's reboot it again
because they love the reboot so hey
remember when everybody loved this one
it will run and let's make a big stink
of Galle coming back to do Wonder Woman
why not bring the dude who drew it that
everybody also loved a huge deal I'm all
for it but it's just I'm all for it
because I loved one of my favorite
comics ever is that what if we're what
if Conan the Barbarian woke up in the
20th century have you ever seen that
book no it's bananas where it's like
Conan wakes up in 1976 in New York like
during a blackout and so it's nothing
but what are these demon code Diamond
dragons and roaming like he's just
hacking Volkswagens to pieces so it's a
Conan version of splash absolutely
it's man out of time it's it's which is
dumbest [ __ ] but I [ __ ] love it too
because what if what I've swore my
jammy-jam like we love what if oh man so
if this is a big what if like how does
how does either Wonder Woman travel back
to this Sumerian the Hyperborean Age
well she's ageless who's a lot back then
yeah or does Conan somehow end up in
famous Kia which again not the worst
idea in the world
no um anyway he gives you [ __ ] like I'll
read it I like I like both those
characters I will just the idea of
crossing over is kind of badass yeah I
mean swords and swords there you go
we're all for that will offer that
Watchmen here's the thing Damon Lindelof
he have lost he of the leftovers he of
Prometheus as ever was indeed
Marland oh I love Tomorrowland he
co-wrote it with what's it said they got
a chance chiptunes your boyfriend my boy
Jeff Jensen
he is talking about and it's early early
early early but doing Watchmen wait for
it as an HP
series now mark when I was a child first
reading Watchmen and late eighties early
nineties yes even the way back then we
would always say this would be a great
HBO show like they should just do this
as an HBO series and so we say the same
thing about preacher said the same thing
about Sandman and [ __ ] like we now live
in a world where that is actually going
to come to pass that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah what do you think did they do the
12 issue miniseries that Zack Snyder so
lovingly put up on the screen I mean the
problem with the watchman has a movie
and I I don't think I like it nearly as
much as you do is that it's such a dense
book yeah that you have to by its very
nature of an adapting it start dropping
[ __ ] out of it you know and and Zack
loves it so much that what we got was a
very literal translation but because you
then have this little transition at the
drop [ __ ] you had like none of the the
pirate stuff yeah like none of these
these positive stand along little
cartoon movie with the pirate stuff yeah
but like none of none of the sort of
metatextual stuff that help deepen that
work to such a degree you didn't really
get the journal pages you didn't get any
of that stuff so like if you're going to
do a version of this show bets you can
give an episode to an issue in like 60
minutes for every 22 page book even go
[ __ ] 5 major and I'm there I'm in the
bag [ __ ]
that being said mark raising that
interesting point before we went I I'm
so literal mind I'm an idiot I'm like
well they made watch him as a movie why
would they do it again or or I said why
would they just remake the why would
they make the miniseries when we just
saw watch my movie but Mark's point was
like maybe it's not the miniseries yeah
I mean we have no Intel whatsoever on
what I was think it'd be but there's
also the world in which I mean the
leftovers was based on Tom pratas novel
he wrote one book and they made three
seasons of TV at some point you have to
diverge from the book Russ and decide to
like take the spirit of the book and
make your own your story out of it
like who the hell knows I mean I would
wager they're not going to do any before
watchman stuff but if you've got this
world this amazing world like what's the
new story you could maybe tell in that
world to follow up oh yeah what happened
after spoilers Ozymandias plan was put
into motion and [ __ ] like that that's
kind of no I've watched that show - look
I'm watching it regardless again it's
like we both subscribed it's showing up
anyone festival we can already own HBO I
don't know if I got HBO [ __ ] I'm in
the bag I actually couldn't stop it from
coming anyway fair we don't want it yeah
but we're just kind of curious where's
where what version are they gonna do but
it's too early to know all we can tell
you at this point is it's happening yeah
and like not for nothing but from the
dude who navigated all of loss and dealt
with what was probably the first real
internet fandom and fan backlash in a
big way like a visit you to understands
the potholes of dealing with a thing
like a beloved thing like Watchmen like
he knows where the bombs are in demand
in comics and he's a years ago the
Jersey Boys huge comics nerd you know
and if you go back and watch lost you
will see all of those sort of comic
references and comic scenes in there I
mean there's there's a handful of people
who could do this and he's one of them
there's oh my god for you yes set man
beautiful world what a beautiful life oh
oh oh a watchman shows in our future and
if air on HBO so they'll be boobies and
a lot of harsh language and lots of
Islanders flaccid dicks that's true yeah
we're gonna get the game of thrones dick
treatment to the Washington if you're
going to see dr. Manhattan's dick which
actually we saw a lot of in that watch a
movie so you're gonna feel like you
think you've seen it all goes on a big
blue dick where do you see the comedians
[ __ ] where did you see the wonderful
Ozymandias [ __ ] not I will dick Thank
You night out [ __ ] cloaca
cuz he's a bird [ __ ] where do you see
the spill some Spector's dick they will
look up in my dick and act up for help I
will it down and say
all right I will drop my dick on their
head
roar sharks dick which is different like
spots all over it changes making what is
it now this is the dick go dick I'm
happy I'm very happy yeah
nobody's asking but I'm happy dick
there it is folks for fat man I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark barnard tune in
next time same bat time same bat Channel
smack aah more youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]